good morning Hank it's Tuesday so this
week my book The Fault in Our Stars is
at number one on the USA Today and New
York Times bestseller list which is
bananas and it's made me think about all
the books I've loved that aren't
bestsellers so hey today I want to
introduce you to 18 books I love that
you haven't read and probably very few
people watching this video have read and
the nerdfighters in comments if you can
leave names of books that you love that
I probably haven't read all read 18 of
them and review them in a future video
okay let's get to it okay let's start
with sports this Bloody Mary is the last
thing I owned by Jonathan Rendell best
book title ever also my favorite boxing
book ever
speaking of unusual areas of my
expertise one of us by Alice domra
Drager which is by far the best
nonfiction book ever written about
conjoined twins it's also just an
amazing book about disability and
unusual anatomies and how people in
power tend to essentialize and
marginalize the author okay a couple
funny books around Ireland with a fridge
by Tony Hawk's not Tony Hawk it's about
a guy who hitchhiked around the
circumference of Ireland with a
refrigerator it is one of the funniest
things I've ever read also excellent
Tony Hawk's is follow-up book playing
the Moldovans at tennis in which he
plays tennis with every member of the
Moldovan national soccer team the
unthinkable thoughts of Jacob green by
yes that is Zach Braff's brother Joshua
great coming-of-age novel worth the
price of admission just for Jacob greens
Bar Mitzvah thank-you notes now you may
have read MD Anderson's the astonishing
life Tavian nothing one of the best
novels of the past decade but you
probably haven't read MD Anderson's
surprisingly brilliant vampire novel
thirsty as being of great wine Oh Cecil
Castle ooh cheese book boy proof came
out in 2005 and the haunting and
beautiful story of this outcast girl
named egg has stuck with me ever since
also a la cartes fly on the wall a
brilliant feminist reworking of Kafka's
metamorphosis so hard to say
metamorphosis they're gonna know about
your Lisp now they already know about
your listen oh no just moving on tre
Jones is most famous for her book
leading Atlanta which is great but this
book the untell encapture is the
precariousness of working-class life
just beautifully speaking of beautiful
the Golden Rule by my mentor Eileen
Cooper if you have a child you may have
noticed that they don't like inherently
excel at empathy this book has been huge
for us and talking to Henry about
imagining how other people are feeling
one new feature books show away by
Jackie Woodson one of my all-time
favorite picture books and also one of
Henry's favorites he Cummings first book
the enormous room I don't know why this
isn't famous it's Cummings memoir of
being imprisoned and falsely accused of
treason during World War one it's also a
brilliant examination of like the
relationship between the individual
and the collective hugely influential
book Susan's on decks regarding the pain
of others which made me think a lot
about the difference between
representing and exploiting pain in art
also in an image saturated age this is
absolutely required reading about the
unreliability of the image death comes
for the archbishop by Willa Cather maybe
the most important novel about American
religion why doesn't every American high
school student have to read this I don't
know a book I'm almost sure you haven't
read this blinding absence of light by
too hard been yelu and I'm probably
saying his name wrong I apologize it's
that that that name this book
fictionalized is the story of real
political prisoners who lived for
decades in complete darkness and six
foot by three foot rooms it's a little
intense but it's really really good
speaking of which Kendra Biko booth her
first book Tyrell is more famous I like
this one just as much the optimist
daughter by Eudora Welty out of fashion
these days but I think the best book by
one of the best 20th century writers
speaking of the south will you miss me
when I'm gone the Carter family and
their legacy in American music this book
inspired an early vlogbrothers video
link in the doobly-doo but it's also
just excellent and finally the last
summer of Reason a novel about a
bookstore owner who lives in a country
overtaken by extremists who believe that
art is evil so there you have it 18
books I love that aren't bestsellers but
should be I look forward to your
suggestions nerdfighters I will see you
in comments Hank I'll see you on Friday